do you
would you so we sort of agree that this
isn't fair yeah like this is we're in
the same which is interesting because i
didn't think that was your stance wow
because when we talked about it last
time yeah it was just
it was that making some good points
you can say it you can say it
i saw i saw this and i thought about
what you said last time about how like
if you work your whole life with
something it's just like
man like i i would cry i don't care if i
got second place i would cry like yo
i've worked so hard did all the training
for this and i don't even know
when she started training for this
i honestly wonder if
and i'm not discrediting her but i i
honestly wonder if
she didn't
how how hard she trained for it to be
able to do it because
essentially she wouldn't have to train
that hard at all to be able to demolish
a record and come in
essentially it's michael michael phelps
the wingspan that
leah has is michael phelps swimming out
there and it's like you can't
you have five six inches of somebody and
your wingspan is just as long as your
height
is like there's there's nothing you can
change about that that's something that
physically
you can't inject growth hormones in your
body the night before
you find out that you're swimming
against this person and try to be able
to make it a level playing field in a
even playing field and it sucks because
the there's people who are
trans women that are able to play but
then you have women who are born
biologically a woman they just
were gifted with more testosterone than
regular women that aren't able to
compete in their sport that they
are both
biologically a woman in i wonder because
you you showed me there was the case um
guys and if you know more information on
this put it in the chat but
um i know there was a case where you
said this girl was supposed to compete
and she couldn't because she naturally
had high testosterone
i was wondering
because what i've found is a lot of
stuff like this there's like more to it
if you take steroids to use your
testosterone go higher oh apparently it
does so i was wondering if maybe they
thought she was on steroids because of
how high her testosterone was
and so how and i know a lot of pro
athletes like do drugs like a lot like
that's like i know a lot of people that
just compete at the high level of like
power lifting and they do it so i can't
even imagine like yeah but i have a i
have a family member who has a
naturally
a lot of testosterone and so
it's not an athlete at all or anything i
could just be like a genetic yeah yes
so i wonder how they like determine is
it just like is there a cut off or
something
that's hard because if there's a cut off
then how are trans women able to compete
yeah i don't know yeah if she wasn't
taking steroids why did she get like
why was she not allowed to compete
that's why just because her testosterone
well that's but that's that's
but that's that's what i'm asking like
what i've found with stuff like this is
there's usually like more to it but they
never
i remember when this happened and i was
like well why isn't she able to compete
yeah they never said anything about
steroids like she took steroids so
that's why she's not competing it was
literally just because her testosterone
level was higher than um
the
regular
i don't know i mean i just think it
should be biological woman biological
like whatever you were born as we should
just comp like i
would you guys support if there was a
lot like next year they're like this is
ridiculous and they said we're banning
no trans women can compete in the
women's division would you support that
um
deep down i'm like yeah because
you know we're women we want to compete
with yeah
i want to work hard um and compete
against women and yeah i'm paying
against women and know that i'm not like
at a deficit and i'm trying i'm not
competing i'm doing all this but because
i am not as good as this person is not
because this person is physiologically
environment biologically like stronger
and in physicality
like i'd rather it be a fair playing
field
my skill level is not up to your skill
level yeah yeah so
just why do you guys hesitate because
it's like a part of it is unfair because
it's like
we're we're in a society now where
people are allowed to be to identify us
whoever they want to be so it's kind of
hard to say like yeah you're allowed to
be a woman but you're not allowed to
take part in women's school
what if i said i identify as a teenager
and started blowing high school kids out
of the water
that
see it
yeah so shouldn't it just be like what
it is
like you can identify what you want in
your personal life but don't you think
from like a policy perspective it should
just be like what it is
because my thing is like if we can't
even advocate for ourselves how do we
expect men to advocate for us if we
can't even advocate for ourselves
it's it's hard because you also want to
be inclusive be inclusive and be
respectful respectful of those decisions
of their choice but
i would tell that to a trans person i
literally i would say and i would say it
in a nice way like look i don't want to
get my ass beat by y'all yeah because
yeah i don't want to i'd rather league
or like the playoff finals yeah
i'm versus like a trans woman yeah like
that i would be pissed off yeah because
essentially like skill level could be
neck and neck but you're always going to
have a leg up on somebody because you
used to be a man i like women didn't
have that opportunity to go
be a man for a second to get all the
physicality of a man and then be able to
go back to women's force and i'm not
saying that that's what they're doing
but it's like that's what that's what as
women like you're missing the only way
we can get that is if we start taking
testosterone and we start taking things
that
give us that leg up
so yeah
i'm going to read super chats really
quick guys we got a decent amount guys
okay just so you guys know
all super chats are being reinvested
into the platform you're gonna see some
updates soon i got a really big donation
for the channel you're gonna see um
multiple cameras we're getting more mics
coming in i get paid um on the 1st of
april so all donations that you guys put
in i'm going to get the money at the end
of the month so um
that's when you can expect the like
updates so send money
because what i would like to do is get a
new table as well that's my new thing
that i'm buying
okay so um zentian's 50 super chat you
are my favorite oh my gosh then teens
you always send in like money money
thanks to feminism we now have eroded
barriers that protected previous genders
in the name of exclusivity the real
question is where does the left put new
boundaries because if you stand for
nothing you will fall for anything
you guys think that
what does it mean by left leg so they're
basically saying if we can't even stand
up if we say like sort of
they're saying the left no no they mean
the left like like all right yeah yeah
okay okay so they're saying like if we
can't stand up and say like that's a man
that's a woman then like and say that
policy is wrong like how are we going to
like protect ourselves that is true
because if we don't essentially if we
don't say like trans women can't compete
we're
we're putting ourselves in
kind of in danger because in sports
especially in a contact sport if you're
going up against somebody and say like
say we're post and we're going up
against a trans woman we're we're about
to get bodied and it could
seriously injure us because
as a even as a guard say you're driving
you're driving uh down the lane and
someone just bumps you a little bit it
can send you flying
like a
career and an injury yeah and i've had
friends who've competed against trans
women i've competed against trans women
and they've told me that
yeah this person came down the lane and
they just bumped me just a little bit
and it sent them like flying and it's
just
you're putting like essentially it's
just a dangerous situation yeah and so
but it's like
it's like you guys are both so logical
like you know this so i feel like we
should be like
like it shouldn't even when i ask you
like would you stand for that policy
like there should be no hesitation and i
and i but i understand because i think
as women we have this like
yeah we want to include people we want
to
and it's like natural times yeah and i
have that too but
i just i i oh my god it just makes me
really mad
yeah
because i i just think of myself like
i've worked so hard to get to this point
so hard like i i've put in god knows how
many hours to get as good as i am
exactly and i can maybe go to europe and
get free housing and a couple hundred
bucks a month yeah and i want to share
that with men yeah
or go to a [ __ ] country and make decent
money but i'll be on an island with more
goats than people like what do i have
for my money
it might even become harder like to get
like opportunities in the future if what
if in the future oh goodness like our
leagues are filled by trans and they
just take it
see that's that's that's where like
it's like but that's what i feel like
like yeah because we yeah because we
keep letting it go and i think that's
what like that's what we did
eight years ago in the instead of saying
like why the hell is caitlyn jenner
getting a female award
remember she got the the courage award
like the female courage award
i don't know
yeah i'm like why the hell is she taking
away like someone else's award
like you're telling me caitlyn jet like
come on like
let's just pull up a picture
wait kate when and so essentially all
the accolades that caitlyn jenner had
before
when she was a man
do those go away now like there's no
more christmas no chris she still has
like the record books or whatever but
that's not that's not
her anymore
i don't know
i think it's it's still like bruce has
like bruce yeah if like a man that's
transitioned was previously a gold
medalist in the men's like 100 million
yeah and they transitioned to a woman is
that still his title or does that get
passed down like
oh i don't
i don't know but like
if me i would just live in reality and
say you can dress up as a girl but you
won't actually be a girl yeah you can be
a trans woman no that's why if i say
like i say trans woman because
you can't carry children yeah you can't
like you don't have to go through pain
once a month
every month every month
you don't have to
that's that's like the one thing that
does upset me is it's so easy for
i'm not saying it's easy for them to
transition but it's easy for people to
say oh you're a woman
and
it's just like there's
there's so much that comes with being a
woman and it's not just to say that
women are just this just that but that
comes with being a woman and there's no
going around and there's no if ands or
buts about it
and
people can come in and transition and
they can choose to be a woman i wish i
could choose not to have a period a
month i can choose not to
have just the womanly things that happen
to us that are hard i wish i could
choose to not have to operate in pain a
lot throughout the day and
it's just that's like the irritating
thing about it yes i want to be
respectful of the choice respectful of
how they see themselves and how they
live their lives but it's just like
it's hard it's like so there's this
this is not about um
uh trans people there's this person
who
born white
they uh
they're talking about rachel donald i
don't remember her name but she got tan
tan tan tan
and she's like
i'm black i identify as a black person
it's just like wait how how
you were
you are not born and she went to africa
and got blessed and everything and
it's not it's not that
there's another she's um
she's from over on this side yeah
but it's like
it's kind of
there's a lot of things that yeah like
you can't just be like yeah one day and
be like okay
i'm a black person yeah what if i woke
up instead instead of the whitest girl
on earth i'm now the blackest girl like
i would be like you know what girl
don't ask me to be on none of your
podcast no more